and speaking of which finally new rule I
don't know if there is a hell but if
there is I'm the trip to get there the
in-flight movie must be Kirk Cameron
saving Christmas but if there isn't a
hell as I suspect I'd like to take a
crack at saving Christmas myself because
I think it does need saving
you know why cuz when the subject of
Christmas comes up now
I notice so many people roll their eyes
and say some variation of I hate
Christmas well I'm not ready to throw
Christmas under the bus I say let's save
Christmas what do you say
all right now I'm sure many of you are
thinking that I'm an odd choice to be
the one saving Christmas but you know
what I have never hidden my affection
for the holiday as long as you don't
take it literally but as a fable it's
cute
I kind of like the story about the
Virgin who has a little god baby in the
barn it's like an early episode of Maury
Povich in the case of baby Jesus Joseph
you are not the father yeah I mean I
never went in for that winter solstice
[ __ ]
I have too many good memories wrapped up
in the word Christmas to me it's about
family and memories and the looks on the
carolers faces when I set the dogs on
Reuben and how can you not love eggnog
you're basically getting wasted off of
ice cream so how did we [ __ ] it up when
did it become such a chore look at all
these books and movies with titles like
how to survive Christmas Christmas sucks
skipping Christmas surviving Christmas
what do people say when it's over hey do
you make it through the holidays
Christmas shouldn't be something you
make it through like basic training or a
colonoscopy or a stretch in the hole
which is my nickname for a colonoscopy
you shouldn't be looking at the open
oven and thinking should I take the
sugar cookies out or stick my head in
so what can we do to rehabilitate
Christmas to get its poll numbers back
up well here's my three point plan first
we got a shorten the season you know
years ago I suggested that since
Christmas really now starts in October
let's combine all of the end-of-the-year
holidays into one big one called
thanks Haleh Whisman thanks Haleh
witness a day when the whole family gets
together in costumes and gives thanks
for a big meal of Turkey and candy and
then gathers around a tree covered in
toilet paper to it to exchange presents
and tell ghost carols second we must
recognize that although stress from
seeing family has always been there it's
gotten worse because thanks to the
internet and Fox News half your family
is now full-on insane and impossible to
talk to
we all do therefore we need to start a
tradition that all conversation around
the table be restricted to the weather
the big game whether Gene Hackman is
still alive what the dog looks like he's
thinking and when are you gonna have
that thing looked at and subjects that
should be off-limits our politics
child-rearing advice weight gain good
things Hitler did and whether the carpet
matches the drapes oh oh and fYI the
kids and their cousins didn't go for a
walk they're in the garage getting hot
sand and finally if we really want to
get rid of the Christmas dress we got to
get rid of the gift-giving yes like in
Canada right okay I'll give you spending
money you don't have to give people you
don't like stuff they don't want right
that's gotta stop preach all that
anxiety over what to get how much to
spend if I buy something but this one do
I have to buy something for that one the
parking the shopping the returning I
tell you sometimes I wonder how my
assistant does it but I thank her and
everybody else on the staff
and I want to say
we'll be back on January night